Salut! Aujourd'hui je vous fait un petit "Mental Fact" rapide sur le détournement d'attention.
C'est l'arme préférée des magiciens, mais la plupart du temps on pense qu'on est immunisé et que ça ne marche pas sur nous
Alors que c'est très compliqué de focaliser son attention sur plusieurs choses en même temps
Par exemple depuis tout à l'heure vous ne voyez pas que ce coussin se balade un petit peu partout dans mon dos, allez-y vérifiez !
[Générique]
Il y a quelques temps Volkswagen a sorti un truc qui s'appelle l'impossible challenge
Je les ai contacté pour savoir si je pouvais récupérer la vidéo dans ma propre vidéo sans qu'ils fassent un atteinte aux droits d'auteurs
Et ils m'ont dit "tu fais ce que t'en veux il n'y a pas de problème"
Je vais donc m'en servir pour illustrer le propos, mais je ne vais pas le faire tout seul
Je vais le faire avec Mélanie que vous avez déjà vu, vous avez déjà vu Mélanie plusieurs fois dans la vidéo!
On va voir si a nous deux on arrive à relever le challenge
Je vous explique
et puis je vous change de place aussi
F: Donc il faut qu'on compte le nombre de tours du ballon + le nombre de rebonds de la balle
+ le nombre de pas que fait le mec
F: Les 3 en même temps je n'ai clairement pas réussi du coup je me dis que si on divise la tache en deux...
F: est-ce qu'on y arrive mieux, tu vois ? ESt-ce que a deux cerveaux on y arrive mieux ?
F: Est-ce que on est deux cerveaux quand on est tous les deux Mélanie ?
F: Tu prends quoi toi?
Mélanie : Je ne sais pas, le plus facile?
F: Fais ça, et moi je fais les rebonds de la balle et le nombre de pas. Tu es prête ?
M: ouais
F: On y va
[Vidéo Volkswagen]
F: Je note mes chiffres parce que j'en ai deux en tête
F: En vrai je me suis aidé de mes mains, pour le ballon tu as trouvé combien ?
M: 25
F: Je valide
F: Vous venez d'échouer avec brio
F: On ne peut pas se focaliser sur 3 actions en même temps, en vrai tu as vu, moi j'en avais 2, j'ai raté les 2
F: Ou alors j'ai réussi les 2 et c'est toi qui t'es foirée!
M: ah si ça se trouve ouais
F: On ne sait pas, on ne sait pas!
F: Bon en fait le truc pour eux c'est de mettre en avant toute l'assistance électronique de leur nouvelle voiture
F: Mais moi mon but c'est de vous prouver on ne peut pas focaliser notre attention comme ça un petit peu partout
F: et depuis quelques années il y a eu des tests d'attention comme ça qui ont été faits.
F: Est-ce que je peux en faire un sur toi? oui ?
M: Oui
F: Oui! elle n'a pas le choix c'est formidable!
M: C'est ça!
F: Je reviens tout de suite, je vais chercher un accessoire incroyable
F: un rouleau de papier toilette
F: le test d'attention est très simple Mélanie
F: Ce n'est pas non plus une vidéo non plus sponsorisée par le papier toilette
M: L*tus
F: bah tu vois on a dit la marque
F: paaah ça fait déjà deux marques qu'on a dit!
M: Oui c'est écrit dessus en plus
F: C'est vrai?
M: C'est écrit sur le pq
F: Ahh bah oui ! mais moi je lis rarement le pq en fait
M: oui bah il est en face de moi!
F: non bah c'est bien, je sais pourquoi tu passes beaucoup de temps aux toilettes
F: Le but de ce test d'attention c'est que tu détermines si je la mets dans ma main droite ou dans ma main gauche
M : Ouais
F: C'est aussi simple que ça. Est-ce que tu es prête?
F: ou pas!
F: Combien?
M: euuuh
M: Là (main droite)
F: ou ?
M: Là
F: voilà
M : quoi ??
F: ou nul part
F: ou en fait juste derrière toi
F: C'est à dire qu'en te faisant focaliser le regard juste ici
F: moi ça me permet d'atteindre un angle mort juste là et qui me permets de faire disparaitre la boule
M: ah ouais !
F: tu as vu?
M: Est-ce que tu peux leur certifier que tu n'as pas vu la boulette partir?
M: Bah non je ne l'ai pas vu!
F: C'est-à-dire que notre attention étant focalisée ici, on ne prend plus en compte ce qui se passe à partir de là
F: Donc dans mon mouvement de poignet je peux faire partir juste ici la boulette
F: Je vais vous faire voir maintenant deux autres vidéos qui sont tout aussi intéressantes
et c'est toujours sur l'attention sélective
Là c'est moi qui ait compter au tout départ avec Mélanie, mais là c'est vous qui allez compter des choses
Sur cette première vidéo je vais vous demander de compter le nombre de passes que se font les 3 joueurs au 1er plan du terrain de basket
donc vous comptez le nombre de passes dans votre esprit, allez-y
[Vidéo : comptez les passes]
La réponse était 10!
Alors déjà je ne sais pas si vous l'aviez ou pas
mais surtout je me demande si vous aviez vu
que durant la vidéo
le panier du terrain de basket disparait progressivement
et si vous ne me croyez pas allez voir!
Ca c'est une expérience intéressante, parce qu'il y a quelque chose qui est en train de changer,
sous notre nez, progressivement, en temps réel
et comme on est focus sur un compte, on ne le voit pas passer
Cette vidéo-là elle existe sur une chaine youtube qui a 4 autres expériences comme ça
donc je vous invite à les regarder, je mettrai les liens dans la description
Là, je vais vous mettre une autre vidéo, il n'y a pas de piège, mais c'est un peu plus compliqué, comme l'impossible challenge
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a 8 ou 9 joueurs sur un terrain de basket et il y a 2 ballons et vous devez compter le nombre de passes collectives
c'est-a-dire que là vous devez réussir à ouvrir votre attention pour compter toutes les passes en même temps
Je vous dit la vidéo, je vous mets le résultat après
ERRATUM : NE COMPTEZ QUE LES PASSES DE L'ÉQUIPE EN BLANC
[Vidéo : Comptez les passes de l'équipe en blanc]
Le résultat était 13, déjà si vous aviez le bon résultat vous pouvez mettre un pouce en l'air à la vidéo
Mais ce n'est pas ça le plus important
Mais le plus important c'est :
est-ce que vous avez vu un ours faire du moonwalk dans la vidéo ?
Je vous assure!
Je pense que là déjà il y a des gens en commentaire qui sont en train d'écrire : mais moi j'avais vu l'ours!
Essayez de ne pas trop spoiler ! Essayez de détourner un peu cette phrase pour qu'on ne comprenne pas
pour que ceux qui n'étaient pas attentifs se fassent avoir comme moi je me suis fait avoir la 1ère fois
Parce que ça aussi c'est une vidéo dont je vous mets le lien dans la description
qui a été faite sur plein d'autres formats, avec un gorille, avec plein de détournements d'attention
qui montrent encore une fois les limites de l'être humain à être multitaches
Alors cette vidéo comme on est au début de la semaine je la voulais plus sur le côté test un peu ludique
Mais là ce qui était intéressant à rajouter avec l'impossible challenge c'était aussi notre incapacité de concentration sur 3 éléments en même temps
et en fait du coup sur 2 puis que je n'ai pas réussi sur 2
Je serai très curieux d'avoir vos résultats aussi
Je vais vous mettre un lien vers leur site
parce qu'ils ont eu la gentillesse de me donner les rush HD de leur vidéo et que je m'en sers dans la vidéo
donc n'hésitez pas à aller sur leur site à faire le test, s'il vous plait il y a 3 autres tests
et à me donner les résultats dans les commentaires de ce que vous avez réussi à faire ou pas. Je vous mettrai aussi les miens...
.. mais c'était pas fou fou...
Mais essayez il y a 4 tests!
Pour ceux qui se posent la question quand est-ce que je vais traiter la collecte des données de la dernière expérience mentale
Sachez que j'aurai terminé de m'en occuper en fin de mois
En attendant, n'oubliez pas de ne pas être silencieux #PASSILENCIEUX
Vous la communauté active comme la communauté passive, n'hésitez pas à vous exprimer à l'aide d'un petit pouce ou d'un commentaire
mais à faire voir que vous êtes là!
et moi je vous donne rendez-vous bientôt, je pense que ce bientôt sera samedi
peut-être avant, pour ça cliquez sur la petite cloche comme ça vous saurez!
[Générique de fin]